وبشان العاجل الذي اوردناه ادته قبل قليل
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل قليل وفيه
اصابه مستوطنه في اطلاق نار على سياره قرب
بلده ع طيرات وسط الضفه الغربيه معنا من
هناك مراسل مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد العمه
اذا وليد الامر يتعلق ب مستوطنه تم
اصابتها هي سياره للمستوطنين كانت على
دوار مدينه روابي التي على مقربه منه
مستوطنه عتير الواقعه
شمالي بلده بيرزيت وشمالي مدينه رام الله
النيران اطلقت على السياره
واصيبت مستوطنه في داخلها كانت مع افراد
عائلتها وتم نقلها بسياره الاسعاف ا
جراحها حسب الاسعاف الاسرائيلي تتراوح بين
المتوسطه والخفيفه قوات الاحتلال دفعت
بتعزيزات الى المنطقه وقامت باغلاقها
بالكامل
وحاليا تقوم بعمليات تمشيط واسعه بحثا عن
المهاجم او المهاجمين الذين اطلقوا
النيران وحتى هذه الساعه الواقع هناك او
الوضع كما وردنا من شهود العيان هناك
اختناقات مروريه وتوقيف لسيارات المواطنين
الفلسطينيين هذا شارع يسلكه الفلسطينيون
كثيرا المتجهين من منطقه رام الله باتجاه
كل القرى الشماليه والشماليه الغربيه
لمدينه رام الله مدينه روابي التي وقع
الهجوم على دوارها هي مدينه حديثه بنيت في
السنوات الاخيره في المنطقه هناك ومستوطن
عطيرت هي مقامه على اراضي قريه عطاره
تحديدا الواقع الشمالي مدينه بير زيت لذلك
النيران اطلقت على السياره التي قيل بانها
اسرائيليه في البدايه ثم تبين انها
للمستوطنين وقد اصيبت مستوطنه كانت في
داخلها والان جيش الاحتلال اغلق المنطقه
ويقوم بعمليات تمشيط واسعه بحثا عن
المهاجمين وليد العمري شكرا جزيلا لك